I'm sharing my wedding day review on
Stephanie better mores all in diet I
received tons of requests for an update
now I actually don't watch a lot of
YouTube myself unless it's for research
and for work but I have been religiously
following Stephanie's journey because a
I think it's amazing what she's doing
and I believe she is a huge asset to the
online fitness community and B I just
love her personality I think she's fun
and obviously super smart and her and I
also share a deep love of all things
Donuts so for this video I'm gonna be
sharing some of my insights into
Stephanie's all-in journey and let you
know what I am really loving about this
transformation that I've seen also a
heads up that I am wearing my
caffeinated and motivated shirt from my
new merch line so definitely hit up the
description for a link on where to get
it now before we get started a reminder
that this information is for education
and entertainment purposes only and is
not intended to diagnose or prescribe
and they you should always speak to your
health care provider about your unique
health needs now before we get to chat
with Stephanie better more herself let's
do a little bit of a recap if you're
just kind of checking in about nine
months ago Stephanie who is a really
huge Fitness youtuber and influencer and
now says she was going to be going
all-in in an effort to help restore her
reproductive hormones reach her natural
setpoint weight and regulate her hunger
and fullness signals the plan was to
allow herself to eat to society every
single day no matter how many calories
it took so at first coming out of a
restrictive fitness competitor diet this
looked like around 5,000 calories a day
but as we've really watched her updates
and journey over the past few months her
weight gain has slowed and she's finding
herself satisfied on closer to maybe
2000 2500 calories which I would say it
would be a totally average amount of
calories for an active young woman like
Stephanie now while Stephanie's all-in
journey stemmed from kind of
physiological concerns like her
bottomless pit
Ariane's and her skewed hormone levels I
have to say that what she is describing
to me is really like intuitive eating
just with another name I'm seeing so
many of the principles of intuitive
eating in really effortless display
throughout her videos that I think she
really serves as a fantastic amazing
role model for those of you who maybe
want to eat more intuitively but who are
nervous or don't really know what it
looks like in real life so today I want
to walk through some of the principles
to see intuitive eating in real life
action so principle number one she's
rejecting the diet mentality know where
my headspace is at this time of year I'm
just making sure that I just like to
stay in my own lane so I'm just doing my
own thing I'm doing and following the
journey that I've set out for myself and
not revolving around like getting
shredded and lean and losing weight so
that's where I am right now I hope that
you guys can appreciate that and
understand that and I'm sure you guys do
yes okay so I get this is so hard when
dye culture is ultimately everywhere and
particularly for a fitness influencer
like Stephanie as dieting and the
pursuit of weight loss or physique goals
are really a particularly huge huge part
of this world but I love love love that
Stephanie is explicitly announcing that
she is trying to kind of quiet the noise
so that she can concentrate on what
actually matters to her most and that is
doing what is healthy and best for her
and her body principle number two she
honors her hunger
[Music]
which I finished that and I want to miss
Joni miss John it's cold outside okay so
this is so simple but I love that she
ate her oatmeal and then she checked in
with herself and was like yeah I want
soup as well even if the things don't
necessarily go together cravings and
hunger do not discriminate and I love
that she's serving herself up round two
without any judgement at all
okay so principle number three she's
making peace with food so if you watched
Stephanie's recent videos you'll see a
solid balance of really kind of healthy
foods juxtaposed against bites of donuts
and pizza it isn't a video of kind of
bodybuilders diets on day one and then a
cheat day on day two like we used to see
a lot of Stephanie's videos show but you
also will hear her talk about food as
being good or bad you know it's just
food I can only imagine it has been an
ongoing amount of work to truly believe
that after operating in the fitness
world for so long but I am really so
proud of her for finding that piece
principle number four she challenges the
food police again I am sure this journey
has not been easy as an influencer let
alone a fitness influencer and I have
seen her mention multiple times on her
Instagram that you know people
frequently call her obese or shame her
for perpetuating obesity with her all in
process I know how hard it is to deal
with trolls especially when you're
already doing something that is kind of
outside your comfort zone but I really
applaud Stephanie for acknowledging the
occasional blip in her confidence but
then just tuning in and really
remembering that hey this is a process
that you're doing for yourself and not
to make anyone else happy principle
number five she understands the
satisfaction factor normally what I used
to do like cheat days like having a bite
of free donuts would only like trigger
my appetite more like I would be like
okay now they made me more hungry for me
now like of course like my capacities
real
hi so I could eat a lot of food I could
eat all six of these donuts but I have
no desire to his mom made us turkey soup
last night we have leftovers and that's
what I want right now like I'm in the
mood to have some turkey soup maybe I
have a little bit more of these later
okay so in this how much do I want to
eat video Stephanie is like trying all
these delicious looking Donuts
sidenote I am also a dulce de leche a
girl but she says that in the past
having a bite of something really
delicious like a doughnut would trigger
her hunger for more donuts but now since
going all in she's realized that she can
have her like her trial bites enjoy
every second of them and then she would
kind of like tire of that flavor or that
sweetness and move on to what her body
was really craving and that day it was
actually for turkey soup she also
mentioned that she might have more
donuts later when maybe you know she was
more actually hungry for them or that
flavor of sweetness was more satisfying
and enjoyable and pleasurable again
which to me is really great it's a great
example of giving herself unconditional
permission to eat you know a lot of
people find that when they have a binge
let's say on an entire box of donuts the
last few bites are definitely not as
satisfying or even delicious as the
first few bites when our taste buds are
actually primed and excited for them so
I think Stephanie has built enough trust
in her body and herself that she knows
that she can wait until those bites will
be flavorful and delicious and
satisfying again because the food will
still be there when that interest comes
back principle number six she honors her
fullness even if something tastes great
let's take a look well in the morning
and I usually don't eat my first meal
until 11 or 12 o'clock because I just
honor my hunger whenever it decides to
come around okay so a lot of people ask
me if they're not eating intuitively if
they skip breakfast now I have to say
some people are just not breakfast
eaters end of story and as long as that
doesn't prevent you from eating enough
in the day then I don't really see
anything unintuitive about pushing back
your first meal of the day until
ready if you're struggling with hunger
cues however as we talked about in my
honor your hunger video it may be a
really good idea to try to schedule
regular meals and snacks even if you're
not particularly hungry until that
sensitivity really does come back but it
seems to me that now that Stephanie's
kind of gone through that process she
absolutely is more in tune with her just
natural hunger cues and and those
rhythms throughout the day and for her
it just means hey maybe she's not that
hungry early in the morning his slices
of toast and that fruit
I feel pretty full like I'm not gonna
lie I don't have any desire to eat
anything more like I could of course I
could eat more if I like force-fed
myself but I have known as I already ten
ething else and I think that that just
shows how much like I've improved and
how much my appetite has improved so it
makes me really happy that I can eat a
meal like a normal person and not still
feel like I could eat the exact plate of
food all over again so I love how
unbelievably happy this progress has
obviously made her feel that is so
incredibly encouraging it would have
been the same thing that I was thinking
if it was eight months ago before I went
all in and before I ate to satiety every
single day before I gained 40 pounds I
would have easily been able to eat that
whole box of cookies like you guys have
seen my cheat days you guys know what
I'm capable of
but I think it's kind of a
misunderstanding or maybe a
miscommunication on my part to explain
to you guys why I'm capable of only
wanting one or even two cookies at this
point now that you know I've gained 40
pounds and I've gone through this whole
all-in process just to quickly summarize
the idea is to eat to satiety every day
then after that like your satiety cues
and your hunger regulating signals in
your body and in your brain kind of tell
you to chill out so after you eat as
much as you want every single day and
I've been doing this now for at 8 months
I have no desire after I eat one cookie
to eat a whole box of cookies my body is
where it's at right now it's doing
really well like this whole process has
worked so well for me I have
very normal hunger regulatory signals if
you watched my all in like science video
where explain you know leptin and
ghrelin and how that kind of is
regulated in your brain especially when
you gain weight and you have more body
fat on your body and your body kind of
tells you that you don't need to put on
more body fat when you're really lean
and you're super hungry it's because
your body wants you to put on more body
fat it's gonna tell you that you're
hungry all the time even though you just
ate that's just not where I am right now
and I think it it took me probably two
to three months of eating a lot of food
like you know up to 5,000 calories a day
to get to that point and since then I've
been like slowly getting better and
better so after a month for I have just
been progressing even more like I feel
like I need to eat even less every
single day to feel satisfied okay so I
think Stephanie does a an amazing job
explaining how going all-in and
specifically gaining weight has
positively impact her hunger and
fullness cues largely by regulating
leptin and ghrelin so she talks about
when you're super lean you have less
leptin in your body which that's the
hormone that tells you that you're full
so basically you just never get that
fullness signal in an attempt for your
body to naturally weight restore another
important consideration that maybe
didn't affect Stephanie so much is that
for a lot of people who chronically diet
there's often a huge psychological piece
here as well so when you restrict and
then cheat or accidentally eat something
that's forbidden even if you're
physically full already it's hard not to
blast through your fullness cues because
your brain remembers the horrible
restriction that you've put it through
in the past and will likely be subjected
to again in the future but when you
allow yourself unconditional permission
to eat and you put intentional weight
loss on the back burner accepting that
hey you might even gain weight in this
process you learn to actually trust your
body and Trust food and trust your
access to food so Stephanie doesn't need
to eat the whole box of cookies in one
sitting if she's not hungry for
because she knows that tomorrow she will
be hungry again and the cookie will be
there and they'll taste even better
because she's actually hungry for those
cookies principle number seven she's
coping with emotions with kindness not
food there have been a few super
vulnerable moments in Stephanie's videos
over the past few months but I've never
gotten the sense that she was dealing
with the Downs with food let's take a
look or was really expecting I've never
talked about this on my channel before
but I'll say it really briefly my mom is
mentally ill I don't want to get into
all of it but she's been sick my whole
life
and it's part of why my sister and I
take care of her and I guess I should
have been I guess I should have been
more prepared for her to have an opinion
on how not being herself because how she
normally is she had a few things to say
about my weight gain and expect it to
bother me I guess I didn't imagine it
would affect me so badly she's really
off right now and she's live in her own
world but it didn't really bother me I
guess and the things that she was saying
was basically everything that I'm
feeling and I do want to give myself a
little bit of credit I think I was
handling criticism from strangers pretty
well it was just that when it's somebody
that's close to you that made it really
hard and I felt like the best way to
deal with it was just to move on
otherwise it was just going to consume
me honestly Stephie you are so strong
I'm sure so many of my followers are
watching this thinking holy I would
crumble how did you make it through but
I feel like you've really proven to us
what an incredible Rockstar role model
you really are and I'm so appreciative
that you've shared your experience so
openly with the world
okay so principal
number eight she shows her body respect
in total I've gained 35 pounds
interestingly my weight kind of capped
out at the three month mark and it
really hasn't changed in the past month
and has more or less stabilized now that
isn't to say that I won't gain any more
weight because I don't want to be
tempted to have feelings of oh my weight
has plateaued so now I can't gain any
more weight which could bring me to a
dangerous restrictive mindset so even
though it's currently plateaued it
doesn't mean that my weight won't
continue to fluctuate so I am so amazed
and so proud that Stephanie has really
made an effort not to have expectations
on this process you know not to have any
strong hope that this is it for the
weight gain or okay I'm done I've gained
enough really quickly I know you guys
lost if I'm going to die like if there's
ever gonna be a point where I'm gonna
diet and just a really briefly
explaining because I hate saying go
watch this video go watch that video
because I don't think you will or I
don't want to make you do that so I'm
just gonna say that I don't need to diet
and I won't because after I eat less and
I continue to eat less my body is way
above its set point it should go back
down to its set point so there is
scientific evidence to support that
people have a set point and my body is
above that so slowly my body should come
back down without any weight to diet now
while I appreciate that this may not be
for everyone I love that stephanie has
found that all the benefits of this olan
journey and gaining weight far
outweighed any future benefits of
dieting for her so clearly staying on
this course is really an act of
self-love and ultimately body kindness
principle number nine
she continues to move her body where did
I get done however on a positive note I
do feel like the goal of building up my
strength and making strength
improvements was definitely achieved
I felt way more energetic and just
better in the gym like even more than my
first month so everything related to my
training and my training recovery only
continues to get better the longer I've
been all in which is amazing however
another challenge I was dealing with
that was way more prominent in
later months than the early months with
that the weight gain that I had
experienced was becoming a lot more
noticeable so stephanie has actually
used her own journey to optimize her
exercise regime and fitness rather than
letting her kind of changing body
prohibit her from working out not
surprisingly when she's not under
feeding her body can better recover from
her workouts and she can actually see
some of those measurable changes to you
know her strength and energy levels now
I don't want anyone watching this to
think that you need to work out like
Stephanie to be successful at intuitive
eating or going all in but I actually
get a strong sense that weight training
and exercise is something that brings
Stephanie a lot of joy and pleasure even
if it does look pretty intense for those
of us who prefer like Pilates or yoga
I personally am also someone who really
does love heavy weight training compared
to like cardio for example and I look at
runners like they're crazy for putting
their body through what I perceive as
hell but in reality some people like
just love love love to run and do find
pleasure in that so I'm glad that
stephanie has an activity and a source
of movement that she really does truly
love and that she can also enjoy it to
the fullest now that she's all in
without risking exhaustion or injury
through under feeding and finally
principle number 10 she integrates
gentle nutrition and respecting her body
really really well so as mentioned
earlier I am loving the real food
variety I'm seeing on Stephanie's
Channel since she went all in even
though she's given herself unconditional
permission to eat whatever she wants
whenever she wants after nine months you
can see that this largely really is
balanced nourishing meals with some
treats peppered in No More full-on cheat
meals needed
thermalized onions mushrooms and a lot
of goat cheese oh yeah it has spinach
too so
this breakfast at Korres for example
looks really satisfying balanced and
super tasty
you know she's got protein and fat in
her onlet some carbs and her toast and
fruit I mean this is an awesome meal and
totally something that I would order
while out myself so I'm doing oatmeal
vegan protein the vanilla but I added
cinnamon and pumpkin pie spice so it's
like banana foster II because I have
bananas in it so it's really good
okay so ditto with these post-workout
protein oats so Stephanie definitely
knows what helps her recover from her
workouts best and this meal has the
perfect post-workout combination of
protein and carbs it's also super
nutritious but obviously something she
truly loves I mean she has it all the
time and she always just talking about
how delicious it is and it really does
look good we got pizza I got the veggie
pizza with chicken I didn't realize that
it gave they put an entire tomato on top
but probably eat that first okay so even
her personalized pizza looks super
balanced and delicious we've got chicken
for protein and tons of veggies piled on
and she also doesn't leave out dessert I
mean she still enjoys some vegan lemon
ice cream and a chocolate cookie without
feeling the need to necessarily eat the
entire box all of these meals are
selected and chosen because they feel
good to her they're truly just what she
finds enjoyable and satisfying and there
is no you know I'm being good or this is
the healthy choice or whatever
Stephanie appreciates that they're just
really tasty and this is what her body
is craving and I just think that really
reinforces how far she's come on this
journey so now that I've given you my
two cents
I want to loop him Stephanie butter more
herself to tell you about her unique
experience so Stephanie thank you so
much for joining me
oh thank you so I think you do a really
great job at answering a lot of the big
questions that everybody has on your
channel so I want to ask you a few that
I had myself first of all being
how has your interest in cravings in
sweet foods changed since going all-in
that's a really good question because so
much has actually changed and I like to
think that I had a good understanding of
what cravings and what interesting food
was prior to going all-in but I don't
think that I did so just to kind of
quickly define when I was super lean
there was no such thing as like
interesting cravings because you just
want everything it's like broccoli looks
good to you yeah so so these words have
different meanings to me at that point
in my life and I think that they take on
an entirely new meaning now and I think
that for the most part you don't also
have to kind of dilute between one month
all in Stephanie and like nine month
olives and two because even fully like
one month in things like crazy they're
like my you know like a obsession with
sweets would kind of like deep it to
decrease like a bit after one month but
now nine months in it's like completely
transformed so now nine months in if you
were to think of my cravings or interest
I I would you know say that they are
pretty normal I still have a love for
sweets I am sure most people do and and
I just think that now is just my my
cravings and interests are much more
normalized where before it to satisfy or
the cravings that I would have it might
be on like a much larger scale of like
I'd walk into a donut shop and feel the
need like I could have all I could eat
the whole shop know now I feel like oh
like I would love to try one or I would
love to try two or something like that
or after dinner like a normal person I
would crave something sweet and it would
be instead of an entire box of Oreos I
would just want one so I do have them
they have so the short answer is
absolutely has changed and now I had
like a true understanding of what those
words actually I think that's so
fascinating and
and I think is really gonna resonate
with a lot of my viewers who are are
really trying to embark on a similar
journey and and find that satisfaction
with not needing to kind of go overboard
and binge and then feel sick afterwards
so I think that that's really amazing to
hear and and yes to some people like
nine months might seem like a long time
but in the context of your life like how
amazing is that that you've completely
transformed your whole life in really
just a few short months oh yeah that's
fantastic now in one video you mentioned
how your body is above its set point
and that you think it's going to come
down so I'm curious why you believe or
how you know that it's you know it's
your way it's going to come down then
it's not at its natural set point at
this moment so if you were to have asked
me before I went all-in I would have
like most people thought that like if
you eat indefinitely as with high
calories you would just eat yourself
into obesity so you have to first to
understand where my thinking is you have
to first like kind of throw that idea
that we know because it's not true
it's known in in many studies that it's
just not true so there are two different
reasons I think that I believe that this
phenomenon kind of happens so the first
is just scientific evidence and the
second is more like what I feel in
physiological papers but the first thing
like if you have soul is first to just
kind of like explain what like setpoint
is means some people like don't like
they ask me all the time what do you
mean by setpoint or like so that's kind
of how it's described in say like
literature they usually use the word
like natural weight and there is a
theory that most humans genetically have
a predisposition to be a certain body
fatness and they like their body of
genetically hovers around a certain
weight and there's a lot of banter in
the scientific community because you
have to also incorporate environmental
factors so there's also a
prevention model but a lot of people
really discussed the the set point
theory model and how your body kind of
regulates body fatness kind of like a
thermostat so the way that it's
generally described it's like it's you
know you were born us or in way of your
physiology is a certain way based off of
your ancestry as well if your
backgrounds with the way that you store
body fatness but somebody from up north
is gonna store body fatness very
differently in so many South Africa and
so all those things are inter individual
or based on your background but your
body likes to sit in a range
I wouldn't say in exact weight and this
range fluctuates throughout your life so
this is very fluid range so I'm actually
pretty lucky because I actually have a
good idea and a good understanding of
what my natural weight is or my natural
step weight is because I don't start
dieting at a young age and a lot of
people did so they really have no idea
what their natural weight is many people
because of pressures maybe they did
vigorous feeding or dance and when they
were younger
they were you know kind of pressure to
be able with a smaller body and I
actually played sports and I played
softball I was small so they encouraged
me to be bigger and I was just I was
always just an athlete that never felt
the need to dive it and the first time I
really got into dieting was when I was
like 24 so up until like 60 like after
like I hit puberty and like went through
all those changes and my body kind of
hung around a certain weight and like
kind of like a like say percent body fat
not really weight that body fat up until
I was like 24 where I decided to do a
bikini competition and that's when
everything changed so I'd like to
imagine that that is kind of where my
natural set weight is now I'm gonna be
thirty this month so obviously time is
gone by and at this place in my life I
don't think that I would go necessarily
to that weight but that was just that
that's kind of a ballpark of where I
think it is and it's where it feels
happy and where I don't feel kind of how
I do right now where I do feel a little
bit uncomfortable and it's kind of
difficult to describe so I'll use a few
the way my body feels right now is
uncomfortable because I'm always like
like oh like so uncomfortably hot all
the time so these are like kind of
physiological signals to me that my body
is kind of like after its peak
I have come down from my peak wait which
by the way I might eat weight for like a
good four months and it did not move for
four months and at the highest week that
I got to you it's only just recently
started to very slowly come down and I
can tell that I don't think my body is
but done because I'm still way above
that like hypothetical natural set
weight I have and but like aside from
being really hot where I'll sit anywhere
and I'll just sweating through my pants
then it's just crazy all the time I also
feel like my appetite is just it's just
like so low to the point where sometimes
I like make myself eat because I like
don't want you know I would tell them
they might by lack of like my appetite
right now but it's very low like I can
barely eat before noon sometimes
sometimes when I eat I feel a little bit
nauseous so I feel like my body is like
okay you are at a high enough body fat
for a while and now like everything is
functioning normally again and maybe
it's it does feel a little bit
uncomfortable and this is like a mental
thing that I have but in terms of
feeling a little bit uncomfortable but I
think that my frame doesn't support this
body weight either because I find that I
walk very funny now hmm and because my
legs are really big and I find that my
gait it's just strange and awkward that
could just be like in my own head but um
that's another thing that I've noticed
and I think that my Franca's may support
this high of a body fat percentage so
that that's purely anecdotal but there
is obviously like I mentioned before
with the 17 model Theory there is
scientific evidence that like in in
overfeeding studies that yes the
participants will gain above there we
were feeding weight but they almost
always come back down sometimes it takes
longer and some
spits than others same thing happens
when you under feet participants
the same thing happens when they go back
to ad libitum eating they can't less
swing back up they have this overshoot
period and then slowly but surely if
that you ad libitum
it comes back down so interesting and
and I love I mean as a as a science
minded person I really truly appreciate
you kind of bringing that science mind
to your journey and sharing that with
your with the audience so that was
that's very interesting and and so you
know insightful as well so okay so next
question this is telling I'm fascinated
by again science geek but you showed us
your blood panel back in the fall and I
know that you weren't satisfied that
your numbers were exactly where you
wanted them I guess in the long term but
have you had your estradiol and FSH and
your LH retested since the fall so
that's a that's a great question and
really interesting that I actually just
booked an appointment to have my blood
work done on Monday when we're reporting
this on a Friday because I have an
update video coming up and I really do
want to after you know a good almost ten
months at that point know where I stand
and I know that in my video that I seem
to be very disappointed and I was at the
time of the recording of that video but
I actually had doctor Nicola Rinaldi we
chat very regularly like all the time
and but right after that video was
recorded that was after my four month
update she actually gave me a lot of
like she really really made me feel so
much better because she actually
mentioned to me that those numbers were
really promising mm-hmm that I shouldn't
feel discouraged by those numbers at all
she said that they were pretty normal
they could be better but they were
actually pretty much in the normal range
and that these things take time and that
after that at that time it was only four
months that I shouldn't feel discouraged
by by any means because it was really
promising so her just giving me that
reassurance made me feel so much better
and of one thing that I'd like to kind
of make note of to your audience this
might be long-winded but I think it's an
important thing to mention that if women
are at all considering getting blood
work because
they need to they want to monitor maybe
these things they're like things seem a
little bit low or seem off make sure
that if you have a normal menstrual
cycle and I can't say this to speak
people who have amenorrhea at the moment
but if you are undergoing like a normal
menstrual cycle you need to get your
blood work done in the same space that
you had it done if you're comparing
numbers because your numbers just change
so drastically between your follicular
and luteal phase like after you hit
ovulation your estradiol applies so like
me and like Peaks plummets same with FSA
chanel age they increase and decrease
throughout different times of your
menstrual cycle so if you were to
compare two different numbers and we're
taking at different times over your
metro cycle they they could be extremely
misleading or discouraging or like
encouraging wrongly urging like all
those things so if you are considering
taking any measurements and having these
things tested just make sure just keep
those things in mind yeah thank you for
for flagging that because I think that
that could totally throw people off and
the other thing I wanted to mention was
yeah going back to your your original
blood numbers I mean I remember seeing
that video and thinking those look
really great to me like like if that
were me I would probably be so excited
so I'm really happy that you know you've
had a chance to kind of think oh you
know maybe maybe that is a really great
sign and things are moving in the right
direction
because yeah I was personally really
encouraged seeing that and another thing
I wanted to mention was that for people
who are experiencing amenorrhea if you
are getting these blood levels tested
because that was a big question for me
it's like like I myself have a men area
from piece post pill PCOS and that's why
I've struggled with infertility and I
remember asking my nurse like how do I
interpret my baseline blood levels
because I don't have a follicular cycle
like phase I don't have a you know
anovulatory phase I don't know where I
am in this point because there is no day
that this was taken on in my cycle and I
think always run this by your own team
your own nursing team and doctor but my
nurse told me that they analyzed
amenorrhea results based on the
follicular phase of the cycle so Jeff
for those of you who are out there who
don't really necessarily have a regular
cycle that might be something to
consider as well cool yeah totally okay
so another question but one thing I was
thinking about when I was think about
your all-in journey is that essentially
what you're describing as going all-in
to me is almost like jumping full force
into intuitive eating which is something
we talked a lot about on my channel you
were like under eating when you started
this whole journey so it does make
absolute sense to me that your weight
would increase at least at the beginning
when you kind of go all-in and you start
eating more intuitively and eating two
full satiety as you described but what
do you say to some of your larger body
followers who want to regulate their
hunger and find their natural setpoint
but who are worried that going all-in
will cause them to kind of spiral
further out of control with their weight
and food in general yes I would
personally say that going all-in is
completely irregardless of your starting
body weight and that's why everybody's
journey will look very different and I
know that they're probably more
reluctant to kind of undergo this kind
of process because they're scared of
gaining weight and this is kind of why
maybe that the you know they've had a
lot of other issues may be going on and
their self-esteem and that their body
image is going to be probably even more
negatively effected and that's maybe why
they've gone through maybe like the
vicious cycle of dying restriction and
maybe binging and restriction and
they've ended up maybe in this larger
body or they they have other they could
even have like PCOS and there's a lot of
things in this so one thing is that you
really have to consider that this is
temporary so I know that it is difficult
like I'm not gonna you know I gained 40
pounds and that's nothing to laugh at
because it is quite a bit of weight and
I because I started out so lean it may
not seem like I am super heavy now but
but it is a lot of weight and if that
gives people who are already starting
out a little bit larger a lot of fear
that they're going to be in like 40
pounds-plus because everyone's journey
looks different I think that the
reassurance that they're not going to
spiral out of control is really evident
in like the literature and in in what
happens when people that are lean go all
in your appetite and spiraling out of
control really doesn't happen because
your appetite does regulate that and
when you don't restrict even if at a
larger body even though they because you
have a larger body you inherently have a
higher metabolism if you calorically
restrict your metabolism probably has
decreased a lot so you can have a
heavier body weight and have a low
metabolism due to calorie restriction so
you need to keep in mind that this
process yes will gain weight but you'll
be fixing all of those things because
like in the short term like I've had to
say to myself I had to remember that
there I have so much life left to live
like you know I'm not eight years old
and I'm worried about this right now I'm
like but do I want to deal with this
forever do I want to feel hungry all the
time forever and I think that even if
you are heavier you're still human this
process works the same way it's just
that your journeys gonna look a little
bit different and that you're just gonna
have to like everybody does you have to
accept the weight gain because what
happens sometimes when you start gaining
weight you get a little bit scared and
then you like restrict a little hair
still there and the thickness old
tendencies might start to come back and
you have to if you if you do that will
undo everything you've done you know
have wasted all the work that you have
done and so if you slowly like dive
straight into eating whatever you want
whenever you want whatever to find the
day than it is and you will gain weight
and you know it you're like okay I know
that I'm gonna give me like it's not
gonna be surprised like oh you know
surprised you gained weight you will but
it doesn't last forever
and the more you go completely all-in I
feel the shorter it takes because if you
slowly dabble into it it'll just prolong
the whole process and just take forever
that's why that's what really pushed me
to like really not restored at all if no
restrictions because I just
it was just going to prolong this and I
just don't want it to do this forever
right yeah that's so so interesting and
and absolutely true like you said this
is what the research shows us and and
you know the interesting thing is for a
lot of people who maybe are in a larger
body who have spent their whole lives
kind of dieting and binging and
restricting and kind of going up and
down like that that yo-yo dieting ends
and weight cycling is inherently really
bad for your health so if you're able to
stabilize your weight even if that means
you're still in a larger body that is a
really healthy place to be especially in
comparison to kind of going up and going
down and and really kind of damaging
your metabolism in the process so I
think there are just so many benefits
regardless of the size of your body to
begin with this is not just like you
said for inherently like really lean
women who have really dieted down to
very small sizes so this is a process
that can ultimately help everyone repair
their their relationship with food and
do it relatively quickly I mean it's
it's quite amazing the transformation
that we've seen happen here so thank you
for sharing that journey that's so
interesting and for those out there who
may be chronically under eating or
dieting regardless of their size and
shape do you have any mantras or you
know words of encouragement that really
helped you push through some of that
kind of fear to just like jump in and
change your diet so drastically when
really you had no idea how your body was
going to change yeah so I would consider
this in two different camps so the first
camp would be for a mantra for women who
have not yet done this who are thinking
about it you know like they need to
they're like I'm so hungry I feel so
tired
I lost my period maybe your hair is
falling out maybe you're just so cold
all the time but many different things
or even some of those things they feel
like this might be what they need to do
to correct their to normalize their
hunger again and to find their natural
set weight and for those people who
haven't yet done it because they're too
scared it's kind of the same idea that I
was thinking of for the larger body
women this is temporary and you have to
remember that this is temporary and if
you can
like my only witch in the world when I
started was that I could fix my hunger I
didn't know how long it was gonna take
but it was so bad and I felt hungry so
like all the time that it made life so
miss your full that if I knew that I
could fix it I would do it and I thought
that to myself like you know gain weight
is something that many people fear the
it's very obvious I mean it's a reason
why people have you know developed
eating disorder you have disorders in
the first place but if you can make this
really like this promise to yourself
knowing that this is going to actually
fix it it's not like it might it
actually will if you do it right maybe
something would be a good idea maybe to
hire somebody who specializes in this
and it in it's only temporary and it's a
temporary thing and you throughout the
process and after the process you will
be hungry anymore to me that was the
biggest draw to other people they might
have other things on their mind but to
me it was just to not feel so hungry all
the time to not go to bed hungry I know
that you have talked about your
struggles with insomnia
you cannot sleep to that point you know
it is the worst feeling in the world
even if you like used to sleep just fine
before you dieted and working your sleep
is likely not the best because you just
feel hungry and will wake up hungry and
and it can be fixed by something that is
temporary and there aren't that many
repercussions the weight gain is
temporary it's not forever you might
have to accept buy some larger clothes
like thrifting larger clothes accepting
that you may not be as lean as you once
were but you're not going to be hungry
anymore and you're not going to feel
tired and you're gonna improve the
relationship with your partner because
you're not as frustrated you don't watch
your partner and envy you all these
estate and you can't and and that is
really that makes you almost mad at them
they didn't do anything
mmm-hmm mad at them for no reason so
that's like the first camp of women
to say that to you but the second camp
of women I kind of want to reach out to
is for a mantra it's for women who have
decided to undergo this journey maybe if
they're the beginning at the middle even
towards the end they've gained weight
and they're uncomfortable and they want
they want to quit like they feel
tendencies and maybe restriction coming
back and and the thing that I sure cuz I
journal very regularly and I've
journaled I every single time to venture
on twice a day at the beginning because
I'm a journal in the morning how I was
feeling it at night I was very religious
with it every single day and the one
thing that I made sure to remind myself
every time I had to put these bones of
doubt was that I needed to remember my
why and I made my why extremely clear at
the beginning I wrote them down over and
over I said them over and over in videos
I said them over and over to people who
just didn't get it like my parents
didn't get it
like I've said them over and over so I
knew exactly what my wife was so all I
had to say to myself was don't forget
why you're doing this but remember your
mind remember your wife and it would
just be something simple that I would go
key to myself like the moment that I
would look do you stay in your own lane
and remember your why and and that's
what really kept me in it and I think
that you know like for it doesn't really
matter if you're in the public eye in my
opinion or not because people think just
as harsh in person your family your
friends and co-workers they're gonna be
just as harsh so I was in a unique
position I was but I don't think it's
any easier for women that are not public
at all I'm thinking sometimes even
harder because those relationships are
very intimate and you're hearing these
harsh words from people that are very
close to for me like for people that I
don't even know I can brush this off but
like for other people when it's their
family or their their friends that they
just don't get why you've gained so much
weight and things like that that's where
it can be really difficult so you have
to remember your why and if people
really love and support you they will
understand your wife with you yeah that
is so powerful and I think that that
alone will help so many people just and
I like the idea of journaling too
because that may just help you reconnect
to it that why when when you're starting
to doubt yourself or those
feelings or thoughts or behaviors are
starting to creep back in okay so
finally last question you mentioned that
you maybe want to write a book about
your all-in journey I would love to know
what the punchline is of course you know
what are the most important things that
you got out or are getting out of the
all a journey that you ultimately want
the world to know I do want the message
of the book to kind of be a form of like
self-discovery in a way because
everything that I did like everything
that my whole life my career what I was
doing on YouTube revolved around the way
that I looked and prior to doing YouTube
it had nothing to do with the way that I
used to be a scientist in the lab and
the way that I looked was completely
irrelevant and then I jumped headfirst
into a world where the way that I looked
and the way that my body was was all
that had occurred basically and most all
that gained me credibility or notoriety
or trust from people though she looks
like that then I could trust her even
though the information could be exactly
the same so I wanted it to be about what
I did in moments and how I like
discovered what is important to me
because at the beginning you you know
all these things are important to you
they have certain beliefs and they
changed so much through experiences
quite like this one
and I wanted to show like the evolution
of my thoughts and my process and my
confidence because my confidence wasn't
even great when I was lean because I was
making content to be lean because it
seemed to do better when I was lean so
it like perpetuated like sustained mmm
and and it was this vicious like when I
was like I can't do this anymore like I
didn't even like the way I looked my
arms were so skinny that I didn't want
to wear tank tops like it was bad like I
didn't even feel that great about the
week like my body image wasn't great and
in clothing I just looked like I was too
small of a human to fit adult clothing
yeah like I I didn't even really love
how it looked been and so gaining weight
although I've had my ups and down
I did start to love myself and my body a
lot more and then the king socialists
focused on my body because I was like
you know kind of thinking of other
things and work and and I didn't want
this book to the adult prescriptive like
people have asked me I even talked to a
publisher and they wanted it to be there
like this great as I out to and I didn't
want to do that because that's not my
that's not my mo I'm not trying to tell
people what to do I just want to share
my journey because they can learn from
experts and from themself like how they
would want to approach like if they were
in a similar scenario and I think
sharing my experiences in really
difficult times and sharing what I was
thinking in these moments like I would a
hardship or like I feeling really bad
about myself like how I just dealt with
it would just be really you know like
relatable in a way and also just they
could possibly help people who are going
through something similar and any kind
of recovery journey that they're
undergoing although might look at
looking different than mine they could
still take away from what I learned
throughout the process and even as I
write the book I'm still not going to be
done so I'm still self-discovery as I as
I finish and as I go through and I
started with my background and how it
got to where it was so as I keep writing
the cookie and I keep you know like my
journey keeps on going I'll be able to
talk on more current things but that's
kind of what it is it's kind of like a
self-discovery journey I love that and I
love to hear you know of course all
those physical issues that you were
dealing with have resolved in our
getting better every single day and that
is fantastic but but just to hear that
even just your love of your body and
just the respect that you have grown for
your body has has improved is so
powerful and so helpful for for women
specifically but really for anyone who
is struggling in their relationship with
their body and food and because we live
in such you know diet culture this is an
issue that really affects anyone
regardless of what their body looks like
so these are these are lessons that I
think we can all learn from
and so thank you so much for sharing
your journey I mean I can't I can't tell
you how inspiring this whole thing has
been I can't what I can't wait to follow
along and to get the book when when that
comes to fruition but guys if you're not
already following Stephanie I highly
suggest that you do and and so we're
gonna of course leave lots of links in
the description so that you can hit her
up and Stephanie you gotta let me know
when you come to Toronto because I got
all the best doughnut shops in I got I
know on the mall I'm also a doughnut
fimo man love it please do because yeah
I think we we have a doughnut date in
our future awesome well thank you again
Stephanie and if you guys like this
video don't forget to give me the thumbs
up leave me a comment below if you have
any questions about intuitive eating all
in maybe Stephanie will pop by and if
there's any questions specific to to her
she can answer them as well but also
don't forget to hit up her channel she's
got so much information about this whole
journey that I'm sure you will all find
really enlightening subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abbey kitchen bye
[Music]